翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
底上げ教育か
飛び抜けた才能を伸ばす教育か
これは多くの場面で議論になることです
飛び抜けた才能を伸ばす教育は
「引き上げ教育」あるいは
「選抜教育」いろんな呼ばれ方をしますが
私は 「出る杭を伸ばす教育」と呼びます
教育の平等性や 公教育の立場では
底上げ教育が重要だと言われています
しかし 私はあえて言いたい
「出る杭を伸ばしていこう」と
長年 産学連携の仕事を進める中で
出会った出来事を通して
なぜ 「出る杭を伸ばす」という発想に
たどりついたのか
またそれをどのように
展開しようと考えているのか
これから皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
私はもともとは半導体の研究者でしたが
偶然 産学連携の仕事をすることになりました
産学連携は大学にとっては全く新しい領域で
新しい産業を作り出すということが
一つのその目的になります
大学の研究成果である技術を社会に還元して
新製品の開発 新事業への展開
そして新産業の創出につなげていく
場合によっては
ベンチャー企業を創るということもあります
皆さんは大学と言うと
「のんびりしたところじゃないの？」と
思われるかもしれませんが
大学では新しい技術の芽を生み出すために
日夜 研究者が血のにじむ思いで
研究を行っています
ただ
実際に産学連携の仕事を進めていくうちに
技術開発が最終的な戦略ではない
ということに気づきました
実は 大学にとって
大切な商品は技術そのものではなく
研究者であり 人材なんです
大学の研究力を強くしようとしたら
研究そのもののことを考えるのではなく
現在の研究者の実力を上げるか
あるいは外部から 新しい戦力を取り込む
ということが必要になります
そこで 研究者にしても 技術者にしても
優秀な人材を呼び込むことや
今いる若い人を育成していくことが
必要になります
特に海外から
優秀な先生をスカウトしようとした時に
いざその先生が
大学に来てくれる段階になったときに
必ず 起きる問題があります
それは「自分の子どもの教育はどうなるの？」
ということです
外国人の先生方のお子さんたちを
英語で教育してくれる学校が
浜松にはないんです
このことが原因で結局は
話が上手くまとまらないということが
ほとんどですが
それは大学に限らず
地域の大手の企業でも
同じようなことが起きていると
聞いていますし
ただ企業の場合には 場合によっては
そういうお子さんたちを
東京や名古屋の
アメリカンスクールに通うことを認めている
ということもあるようです
地域に優秀な人材を呼び込むために
待遇、研究環境
あるいは職場の環境など
いろんなことを考えましたが
結局は 子どもの教育で
決まってるんではないかと
思うようになりました
ただ どこにでもあるような
単に英語での教育というのではなく
何か浜松らしいことはないか？
地域の産業を振興するために
研究者や技術者あるいは
産業人材を育成することが重要ですし
それは大学や産業界にとっても課題です
しかし 今 本当に求められているのは
目先の教育ではなく
将来の日本や世界をリードしてくれる
子どもたちを
浜松で生み出していくと
そういうことではないかと思っています
他に例のない
理数系の教育システムを作って
イノベーションを起こせる人材を世界に向けて
輩出していったらどうかと
私自身は理数系の出身ですので
あるいは浜松は世界的に見ても
産業が集積していて
大学の工学部や医学部
その両方を持っているという
環境が整備されていますから
理数系の尖った子どもたちを
積極的に育成するということに
集中することを考えました
それが『トップガン教育システム』です
最初は
市内の理科が得意な小中学生の
自由研究を指導すると
いうことから始まりました
また
子どもたちにはちょっと
難しいかもしれませんが
高校や大学のレベルの
理科の授業を体験してもらうこともやりました
また浜松には多くのものづくり企業があります
企業技術者のOBの皆さんに
講師をしていただいて
ものづくり教室も 開いてきています
ただ 理数系と言いながら
算数や数学に関しては
ほとんど活動してこなかった
そこで 子どもたちに
数学的な思考の楽しさを伝えることや
優秀な人材の発掘を目的に
浜松市内の小学生を対象に
『MATHやらまいか』という
算数ゲームの大会を始めることにしました
１ヶ月間ネットの上で
予選大会を開いて
上位30人の子どもを招待して
浜松科学館で決勝大会を行っています
昨年は市内82の小学校から
1,038人の小学生が参加してくれました
ちなみに
昨年の決勝大会の問題を
ご紹介しましょう
五角形のサイコロがあります
この五角形のサイコロの中に
10個のマスが切ってあります
その中に０から９までの数字が
ランダムに配置されています
このサイコロをコロコロコロッと
転がしたのが その隣の五角形です
もともとの五角形と
新しい五角形のサイコロ転がした後ものの
同じマスの数字を足したのが一番右です
みなさん ここまで ついてきてますか？
（笑）
この最後に数字の足された
マスの数字から
もともとの五角形のサイコロ中の
数字を当てるのが問題です
ステージ１の問題はこれです
ステージ１は一番やさしい問題です
ですから最初にいくつか ヒントが
マスが開けて教えてくれています
あと サイコロがどれだけ転がったという
サイコロの回転数も教えてくれています
これ一番簡単な問題です
ステージ４はノーヒントです
最後の足された数字から
一番最初のサイコロのマスを当てるものです
多分皆さんにはそんなに
難しくないかも知れません
（笑）
去年の一位だった子はこの問題を
１時間の間に20問中18問解いてくれました
上位４人のうち １人は小学４年生の子でした
情報学を専門にしている静岡大学の学長
この中に知っている方もいるかもしれませんが
あと 浜松医科大学の遺伝学の
世界的権威の副学長が
連携してこの問題に取り組み ましたが
１時間に２問しかできませんでした
（笑）
このお話で上位の子がいかにすごいか
みなさんお分かりいただけると思います
上位入賞した子どもたちは
トップガンのプログラムの参加や
あるいは
静岡大学工学部での
数学の指導が受けられるようにしています
私たちは
このように 飛び抜けた子どもたちの
「出る杭を伸ばして」
「得意」を「特異」となるところまで
引き上げていきたいと考えています
『MATHやらまいか』は今年から
浜松市外の小学生も
参加できるようになりました
将来的には世界大会にしたいと
考えています
また この4月に
静岡大学の付属浜松中学に
トップガンの拠点を整備することができました
付属学校の子どもに限らず
科学に興味のある子どもたちが
誰でも自由に出入りできて
博士を持った研究者を教員として配置して
子どもたちが分からないことを
いつでも相談できるような環境を
作っていきたいと思っています
また 『MATHやらまいか』に限らず
いずれは浜松で科学コンテストも
開いていきたいと思っています
新しい産業を創り出していくには
２つの能力が必要だと言われています
ひとつ それはイノベーション能力と
インプルーブメント能力を言われています
これまでの日本の産業界は
インプルーブメント能力に注力していて
アメリカで作られたものを改良することに
よってビジネスしてきたという人がいます
もちろん このインプルーブメント能力が
重要ですし 不可欠なものだと思います
一種 底上げであるこの能力は
学校でも大学でも
育てることができると言われています
一方で イノベーション能力は
多様な価値観の中で
ある意味 突出していなければなりません
そういった人材が本当は
日本にもいっぱいいるはずです
問題は そういった人たちを
見つけ出して育てることです
正確には 育てるというのではなく
いかに潰さないで その出る杭を伸ばして
いく環境を作っていけるかだと思います
これからはイノベーションを起こさなければ
新産業の創出はかないません
決められたことを決められたように
きっちりできる 「勉強のできる人材」
それだけでなく イノベーションを起こせる
突出した人材の育成が重要なんです
私たちはこの教育システムで
子どもたち一人一人の
「得意」を伸ばして
「特異」にしたいと考えています
自然に親しむ気持ちや 人格形成
あるいは基礎学力の習得も重要ですが
何より重要だと考えているのは
創造力を育てることでしょう
問題があったり 障害のあるお子さんを
支援することは重要ですし
絶対に必要なことです
それに関しては
誰もが文句なく認めています
しかし 尖った子を支援するというと
途端に みんな 不公平だと
反対になります
私たちはエリート教育を進めよう
としているのではありません
子どもたちは
自分では気づかないかもしれませんが
誰もが得意なことを持っています
宝を抱いて生まれてきているんです
もう 理数系は十分だから
東大に行くために
国語や社会を勉強しよう
そうではなく
得意な理数をもっと 伸ばそう
苦手なことを
補うことばかり考えるのではなく
得意なことを さらに伸ばしていくことでしか
これからの世界とは戦っていけないと思います
どれだけいい人を育てられるのか
そういう仕組みをこの街が持っているのか
素晴らしい人をいっぱい輩出できる
街になるかどうか
それが浜松の将来にとっても
大切なのだと思います
子どもたちの「出る杭」を伸ばしていきたい
性格的にはみ出てしまう子も排除しない
どの子にも誰にも負けない
得意なこと があるはずです
研究者にとって
重要な資質は何か
よく聞かれます
研究をしていても
誰もが新しい発見に
巡りあえるとは限りません
発見に巡りあえるかどうか
その分かれ道は研究者に
本物の探求心と独創性があるかで
決まると思います
この２つを持って地道な努力を続けていれば
いつか
新しい発見ができるでしょうし
新しい発明もできるでしょう
よく 発見はあたかも偶然だったと
言われることがありますが
それをなし得た研究者にとっては きっと
それは偶然ではなく必然だったはずです
しかし
新しい技術を作り上げていく
そういった人真似ではない技術を作る
独創性や創造力を育てていくためには
場合によっては
常識が壁になることもあります
時としては教科書に書かれていることを
疑ってみることが必要なこともあるでしょう
私は「出る杭」を伸ばすことこそが
この 独創性と創造力を育てることだと
信じています
私が理数に関わっていることから
トップガンは
今 理数に特化されていますが
浜松市では
音楽、芸術、スポーツに関しても
子どもたちの「得意」を
のばす教育を進めようとしています
自分が得意なことを
もっと先までやりたいという子ども達を
なぜ止めなければいけないのか？
止める必要はないんです
今 静岡県そして浜松市は
人口減少に悩んでいます
教育を街の魅力として
世界中の人が
自分の子どもを浜松で育ててみたい
そう思うような街になりましょう
30年後に世界中で大活躍して
ノーベル賞やフィールズ賞を受賞したり
新しい科学や新しい産業を
生み出すような子どもたちを
浜松から一杯育てていきましょう
みなさん ぜひ
お子さんの「得意」を
見つけてあげてください
また ご自身の「得意」も
見つけてください
それはどんなことでもいいと思います
そして その「出る杭」を伸ばして
あげてください
大きな鉄の扉を開けるのは
力ではなく小さな鍵です
誰もが１つその鍵を持って います
大きな未来の扉を開ける鍵を
（拍手）